♪ ♪
>> Laura: NOW JOBLESS CLAIMS
SHATTERING ANOTHER RECORD.
THAT’S NOT A RECORD YOU WANT TO
SHATTER, FOR THE SECOND WEEK IN
A ROW.
THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS FILING
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS SPIKED
TO 6.6 MILLION PEOPLE, THAT’S
MORE THAN 10 MILLION JOBS LOST
IN TWO WEEKS.
IT IS TERRIFIC AND IT IS
DEMORALIZING.
IN THE REALIZE WHEN REAL PEOPLE
BEHIND EVERY STATISTIC.
BUT MY NEXT GUEST IS AMERICA HAS
THE ABILITY TO COME OUT OF THE
STRONGER THAN EVER BEFORE.
JOINING I WAS CUBAN, FIRST OF
ALL, I’M A MASSIVE FAN
OF -- WE NEED SHARK TANK
THINKING RIGHT NOW.
BUT PEOPLE ARE REALLY DOWN, I’VE
GOT TO TELL YOU.
I’M GETTING EMAILS, PEOPLE ARE
SO DOWN FOR A WHOLE BUNCH OF
REASONS, BUT A LOT OF THEM
RELATED TO NOT BEING ABLE TO GO
TO WORK OR THEIR CHILDREN GO TO
SCHOOL.
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN COMING OUT
OF THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH A RESET.
I DON’T KNOW WHEN WE’RE GOING TO
GET FROM AMERICA 1.02 AMERICA
2.0, BUT WE WILL GET THERE.
AND WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS WE
HAVE TO REALIZE THAT WE ARE THE
MOST ENTREPRENEURIAL COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
THAT WE ARE A COUNTRY FULL OF
PEOPLE WERE GOING TO START
BUSINESSES AND THAT’S WAS GOING
TO LEAD US THROUGH ALL OF THIS.
SOMEBODY HAS A VISION OUT THERE
OF WHAT WE ARE GOING TO LOOK
LIKE ON THE OTHER SIDE AND WHEN
WE LOOK BACK IN FIVE YEARS, WE
ARE GOING TO REALIZE THAT THERE
ARE FIVE OR TEN OR 25 AMAZING
COMPANIES THAT WERE STARTED THAT
JUST CHANGED THE WORLD AND LEAD
US THROUGH ALL OF THIS TO A
BRIGHTER FUTURE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, MARK,
WHAT A LOT OF FOLKS ARE TALKING
ABOUT ARE OUR RELIANCE ON CHINA
FOR BASIC NECESSITIES.
THINGS LIKE GENERIC DRUGS, A LOT
OF THESE ANTI-INFLAMMATORIES, A
LOT OF THE SUPPLIES THAT WE
DON’T HAVE.
WE HAVE TO GO BEGGING AND
SCRAPING AND BOWING TO A
COMMUNIST COUNTRY THAT
SUBJUGATES ITS OWN PEOPLE AND
LIES ABOUT A DISEASE TO BE ABLE
TO GET OUR OWN STUFF.
WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN ON THAT BASIC
LEVEL?
>> THERE’S TWO QUESTIONS THERE,
ONE IS WHAT DO WE DO IN GENERAL
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING A LOT OF
OUR SUPPLIES NOT BEING AVAILABLE
AND NOT BEING DEPENDENT ON
MANUFACTURERS IN CHINA AND
AROUND THE WORLD.
FIRST THING WE NEED TO DO IS
START INVESTING IN THE FUTURE OF
MANUFACTURING.
NOT TO TRY TO RECREATE WHAT WE
DID IN THE PAST BUT LOOKING
TOWARDS ROBOTICS AND SOFTWARE
AND AUTOMATION IN SUCH A WAY
THAT WE CAN JUST DOMINATE THAT
AREA.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED THAT IF WE DON’T DO IT
THE OLD WAY HAVE MANUFACTURING
LINES WE WON’T HAVE ENOUGH
EMPLOYMENT, BUT THERE IS SO MUCH
INTELLECTUAL CAPACITY HERE THAT
I THINK REALLY WE CAN TAKE
ROBOTICS TO A LEVEL WHERE WE
BRING BACK ALMOST ALL THAT
MANUFACTURING AND CREATE A
SURPLUS OF JOBS.
BUT WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THAT AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, I TRULY
BELIEVE IT’S GOT TO BE
INFRASTRUCTURE 2.0 WHERE WE
FOCUSED NOT JUST ON REDOING
STREETS AND ROADS AND BRIDGES,
BUT FOCUS ON ROBOTICS AND FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES SO WE CAN DEFINE
AND TAKE OVER IN THE FUTURE.
>> Laura: AND THAT MEANS THAT
AMERICAN COMPANIES, MARK, DOES
IT NOT -- THEY HAVE TO THINK
PATRIOTICALLY TOO.
AND PEOPLE HEAR THE WORD
NATIONALISM, AND THAT’S SCARY, I
GET WITH THEIR SKIN
, BUT IF WE DON’T HEAL
OURSELVES, WE’RE NOT GOING TO BE
WORTH ANYTHING TO HELP OTHER
PEOPLE.
I’M NOT GOING TO WORRY ABOUT ANY
COUNTRY, OTHER COUNTRIES, WE’RE
NOT GOING TO FUND THE MILITARY
UNTIL MY KIDS CAN LEARN TO DO
ROBOTICS IN SCHOOL.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO WANT TO DO
ANYTHING, SO WHAT ABOUT THAT
ASPECT OF IT?
>> THIS IS JUST GOOD
OLD-FASHIONED CAPITALISM WITH
SOME SUPPORT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
WE INVESTED IN NASA, WE WANTED
TO GO TO THE MOON, THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO GO TO MARS.
RS.
WE INVEST AT THE NIH, NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH, MOST OF THE
SINGLE MOLECULE DRUGS THAT COME
OUT OF THEIR LEAD TO THE BIGGEST
DISCOVERIES THAT ARE PHARMACY
COMPANIES HAVE.
IT’S NOT UNUSUAL TO INVEST IN
TECHNOLOGY TO LEAD THE WAY IN
THE WORLD AND THAT’S WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO.
MOST OF OUR DRUGS COME FROM
CHINA AND INDIA.
THEY ARE NOT WELL-CONCEIVED AND
WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT BACK OVER.
BUT THIS, AGAIN, THIS IS WHAT
CAPITALISM IS ALL ABOUT AND THIS
IS WHY I KNOW WE CAN MAKE IT
WORK.
>> Laura: AND MARK, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING FOR YOUR MANY, MANY
EMPLOYEES DURING THIS DIFFICULT
TIME?
I KNOW WE ALL EMPLOY PEOPLE --
I’M LUCKY ENOUGH -- I DON’T HAVE
ENOUGH -- AS MANY AS YOU TO
WORRY ABOUT BUT I’M KEEPING MY
EMPLOYEES ON.
YOU JUST HAVE TO.
>> GOOD FOR YOU, LAURA.
WITH THE MAVERICKS, EVEN OF THE
NBA SEASON HAS BEEN SUSPENDED,
WE CONTINUE TO PAY THEM AS WE
ARE CONTINUING TO PLAY.
I HAVE A RESTAURANT IN L.A.,
WHERE PAYING THE BAR BACKS, THE
BARTENDERS, THE WAITERS, THE
WAITRESSES, EVERYBODY IS IF WE
WERE STILL OPEN AND WE’RE DOING
THAT FOR OTHER COMPANIES AS
WELL.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO CAN AFFORD
IT, IT’S JUST THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
>> Laura: AND DO YOU THINK THE
STIMULUS -- A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CALLING ME UP SAYING I KNOW THEY
HAD TO DO SOMETHING, BUT IT’S
NOT GETTING TO THE SMALL
BUSINESSES -- THE BUSINESSES
THAT DON’T MAKE THAT 500 PERSON
CAP.
THEY’RE WORRIED ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO PAY THEIR RENT, PAY THEIR
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE LOANS AND
SO FORTH, ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT
THAT?
>> NO.
ACTUALLY I THOUGHT IT WAS A
GREAT MOVE.
GET THE ADMINISTRATION A LOT OF
CREDIT.
IF YOU OWN A SMALL BUSINESS WITH
UNDER 500 EMPLOYEES OR EVEN IF
YOU OWN A FRANCHISE THAT’S PART
OF A LARGE ORGANIZATION WITH
MORE THAN 500, YOU NEED TO GO
RIGHT TO SPA.GOV RIGHT NOW AND
THEN GO TO YOUR BANK AT MIDNIGHT
BECAUSE THAT’S WHEN IT OPENS UP.
ANY COMPANY WITH UNDER 500
EMPLOYEES, THE GOVERNMENT WILL
PAY YOUR PAYROLL FOR THE NEXT
THREE MONTHS IF YOU DON’T FIRE
ANYBODY AND POSSIBLY HIGHER
PEOPLE, YOU DON’T HAVE TO PAY IT
BACK.
THAT’S THE BEST DEAL EVER
OFFERED IN THE HISTORY OF
BUSINESS.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, MARK,
IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU, COME BACK